Якщо нас спитають, яка наша мета
візиту до Німеччини
що ти скажеш?
Світлану та її доньку Юлію
навряд чи таке спитають
У них на руках довідки про повернення в Німеччину
після примусової депортації в Україну
Уся родина Хіміонових - Світлана, її чоловік і двоє дітей
жили в Німеччині вже два роки
вони втекли з окупованого Донецька в січні 2015-го
Хіміоновим не надали статус біжеців у ФРН
та вимагали залишити країну
Врешті-решт у липні серед ночі німецька поліція
забрала родину із дому в місті Нюрнберг
і посадила на літак до Києва
Я не знала, де зупинитись і що взагалі робити далі
Я авжеж порожнечу відчувала, безвихідь,
і безнадійність, і безпорадність
І розумієш, що так не має бути, але це відбувається
І це було незаконно!
І дійсно, це було незаконно
так принаймні через десять днів після депортації
поставновив суд у Баварії
І зобов’язав відомство у справах іноземців
повернути родину до Німеччини
За кошти держави. Але навіть з квитками на руках Світлана хвилюється
Долетіти б до Німеччини і тоді,
думаю, все буде добре
Долетіли і вдосвіта на роботу
Світлана вже два роки вчиться на доглядальницю
і працює з людьми похилого віку ось у цьому німецькому притулку у Нюрнберзі
*тук-тук*
Ґутен морґен!
Попереду ще рік навчання
і згідно з німецькими законами
протягом цього часу
їй дозволено перебувати в країні
А потім ще і працювати два роки
Ось чому суд став на її бік.
Колеги цьому дуже раді
Вітаю тебе з прекрасним поверненням!
Це дуже-дуже добре
Друзі на роботі і в школі, адвокат
і навіть місцевий пастор
весь цей час вони підтримували українку
збирали кошти на допомогу,
писали листи місцевій владі
і навіть президенту ФРН
боролись за її повернення, хто як міг
Ми всі були дуже шоковані
що вона так раптово мала поїхати
Це був величезний шок
І ми сподівались, ми просили,
щоб вона повернулась
*Чекаємо на тебе в Німеччині
А це плакат, на якому свої побажання написали
всі друзі з Німеччини
коли Світлану та її родину депортували в Україну
Навіть її шеф пообіцяв залишити за Світланою робоче місце
і чекати на її повернення
Вона дуже добре працює
і дуже добре вивчила німецьку мову
і я дуже радий, що і вона, і її родина
повернулись назад
Пані Хіміонова отримала
дозвіл на роботу до кінця навчання
і ми дуже зацікавлені в тому,
щоб і після цього вона у нас працювала
В Німеччині дуже гострий дефіцит доглядальників за людьми похилого віку
Адже робота дуже важка і малооплачувана
Саме тому досвід Світлани, яка працювала медсестрою в Донецьку
цінують у цьому притулку
Незабаром в Нюрнберг має прилетіти її чоловік
Чи зможе воззєднатися з родиною повнолітній син
має ще розглянути суд